yeah bro
what's what what's how how are we going
to do this bro
because this is this is going to be a
yeah this is gonna be a
difficult video to do yeah we need to
come out you see the fingers here
what i'm kind of not scared of but the
thing is you know with people's
perception in it
yeah so for example um
because the thing is you know that for
example you have confronted like
these uh angel challenge support yeah
the reason i do is because look i always
mentioned
i always say look they talk like us they
walk like us
um and when they do when they carry an
attack or whatever they do
we get the blame you get it yeah so
that's the reason why i'm really harsh
with them because
at the end of the day the prophet
sallallahu alaihi if you look at it
you know he had enemies the christians
and the jews and the pagan arabs
but he was not as harsh towards them as
much he was with the
yeah the process said if i lived at
their time i would have destroyed them
like odd allah destroyed art the other
people have out yeah
now why was he so harsh this is the
question why is it so hot did you get it
and these these people were like you
know if i'm saying one of them
came and grabbed the prophet or said oh
fear allah
yeah can you imagine this coming to the
messenger of allah and grabbing him or
others
who says that to a prophet brother are
you okay and the prophet salallahu said
that through this man's knillage
they're always going to come till the
day of judgement yeah so these people
that's why i'm i'm trying to gather it
in a way so when we do the video
i don't want it to seem like i'm trying
to like defend her because
that's what they're doing what [ __ ]
number that's what i'm saying what she
did was wrong
yeah and this is the reason why i'm so
harsh with these people people yeah why
[Music]
no we have to because she's gone there
and she's now she regrets it she's the
cause of
two innocent kids babies their own
children
dying yeah and a variety of other stuff
and i know families and i've heard this
where they're crying
because their families got brainwashed
yeah that's why i speak to some of these
guys who are on this wavelength like
this madness and i say to them don't
fall into this do you get it and it says
we want i want to comment angle where it
doesn't seem like that you get it
people are stupid though bro the fact
that they see baited people talking
about this they're going to think
no exactly exactly exactly oh see
you guys it's not that what we're trying
to say here is this year
you have a set of laws our british
government has a set of laws yeah okay
and they live by that yeah okay you live
and die that's what they're saying
they're saying
you have to live and die you get it yeah
so if that's the case
then you have to stick to your
principles do you get it
yeah because if that's look you can't
have one set of rules for someone else
another set of rules for
so what else because right now when this
is going in and you're revoking a
british
citizenship yeah okay even though you
should bring her and she'll be trial
deal
yeah that's the law of the land you have
to be consistent yeah
what's that what's her name i forgot her
name uh that feels scumbag's
wife yes yes
but you want to bring her into it of
course i'm going to bring that into it
bro how are you not gonna bring into it
because if you think about it here look
she is the wife of this terrorist he's a
terrorist he's killed more people than
this
silly girl who's gone there yeah she got
brainwashed she got groomed
yeah she's gone there and that's why i
said she's gonna bring in that groom
thing yeah
oh of course i'm gonna yeah did she
should kill anybody
did you get anyone uh i don't think so
we don't know
as far as we know this guy this woman's
husband killed four hundred thousand
forget that she tweets supporting him
yeah so one second then why is her
british citizenship not revoked that's
point number one point number two as you
know we did a video about the um
so israel had carried out an attack
killing 1400 people and some americans
and british people went there to
fight yeah but if you say that in the
video you're going to be seen as an
empty semi
we said that in one series that's not
fair so okay i'm i'm i'm not allowed to
criticize anything okay
i'm going to be calling you all but just
be careful with israel isn't it
no no but who cares i don't care bro you
have to be real do you get it
i'm talking about it i get that imagine
now let's try this trick with me
it's not going to work i'm talking about
zionists here yeah 1400 people got
killed
god knows 500 of them were children if
i'm not mistaken here
these british citizens went there
fought they have blood on their hands
and they can happily come back
oh no he's another thing is
anyways because even namaz went there oh
remember yes yes yes they bring him up
now one second this guy he was an adult
yeah yeah he even admitted himself that
he was trying to recruit
military man to carry out yeah so he was
on some next madness yeah
and he was going about he wasn't like
and he said oh yeah you know i was
brainwashed et cetera he was a flipping
adult
exactly she's eight she was 15. she's 15
minor
and most of the times come on yeah when
a girl gets groomed
yeah however yeah be it with these
grooming cases these combat
be it these flipping flipping pedophiles
whoever it may be yeah
you have sympathy for the girl
don't you i'm not saying in the video
please hurry up because we need to film
this here so just quickly yeah so
all right so when a white girl gets
groomed at 15 yeah
people blame the asians yes yeah but
when
an asian girl gets groomed at 15 yeah
people blame the girl
see this is what i'm saying but you see
this is what really you know
what they're saying a funny smile to
gender where yeah yeah they'll really
buy it and they'll be like
you're laughing uh it's a joking matter
to you that's what's gonna happen see
you can't even smile
see this is where do we go what do we do
then we can't do this we can't comment
from this angle all right what if i say
if your son joined the gang at tender
age and decided to come back
would you turn him away and say go and
do one of me
no you won't see that's what i'm saying
you would have sympathy but for some
reason because of her situation
nobody is having like it's weird so if
she's afraid
if this if this this one's in if it was
a white british girl
who went and joined yeah i was thinking
symptoms because i haven't got time
to go as well yet let's let's wrap this
up to do it the proper way and then we
can film it yeah
okay so all right
so imagine this girl went to
and joined flippin lord resistant army
in africa yeah yeah
who uh christian extremists cure muslims
yeah okay
and she said look um well
they're gonna say okay this girl [ __ ]
wasn't it
yeah she said she doesn't regret
anything that she did yeah
yeah so let's suppose this girl came to
look i don't regret anything yeah
at this point you're still going to be
thinking this girl's still in that
brainwashed mentality yeah for you to
think that you get it you're not going
to revoke the citizenship and tell her
to
duck out yeah do you get it how and
another thing is how does that make you
feel how does this make me feel i feel
like i'm
a second-class citizen yeah bro you are
and i was reading a tweet like from
brother dilly
yeah brother dilly and few other people
and you see in our
six pillars
tweet and he was saying like our
forefather fathers had some wisdom
yeah yeah because he said um they're
gonna send this back
to see that don't you that was simple no
why because imagine
because most of you know we told okay
you know make build uh back home you
know
uh how's that that's gonna that's gonna
seem dodgy people are gonna think that
we're ungrateful we're already preparing
i'm grateful they're gonna think we're
going to leave bro
i'm leaving this country you can say
here
the problem is i don't want to leave it
as well but it looks like we're on our
way out because
if tomorrow anything can happen but it's
a chain reaction if it can happen to her
she's seen as that you're not british
anymore yeah
fact that can happen to me they can just
come and say to me you know what
we think you're a bit extreme you know
you're being too long
yeah yeah you do a lot of um i don't
know videos um
i don't know whatever do you get so they
can use that against us so where is this
going to stop
okay
look good for the radio but yeah
i can't say that yeah
yeah we'll come to that yeah um all
right so i've got magic with touchdown
imagine there was we talked about the
cutting edge the the british um
wife yeah yeah um this is pathetic bro
and then our case is strong this is
pathetic you think about it joseph's
side
imagine there was yet this guy he went
on a madness
with british citizens going and joining
israeli forces yeah yeah
okay illegal in an illegal war killing
people
murdering 1400 people they're happily
coming back
yeah bachelor assad's wife who supported
him and he still needed half a million
people
this is this is and the fact that
and the fact that this is this is mad
you know what's very interesting
and this is one reason they want to come
out bricks there so they can say you
know what you lost there you go yeah
this is just
can you imagine we're still in the eu
and this is happening
yeah so imagine well that's what the key
thing is bro
that this would set a very dangerous
standard if this can happen to her today
it's going to be used as a reference
point for anyone else yeah that's the
key
thing bro exactly we're not justifying
anything but we're just trying to
you know let these people know that
that's
what the main thing is that tomorrow can
be used against you it can be used
against
your friend it can be usable against
anyone once the law
gets twisted and the government starts
working like that
it's problematic but that's that's the
sick point man you should turn the
camera around
don't forget that point you mentioned
but this was a very good point yeah yeah
i think
let's just end with that isn't it yeah
we're going to end the video with
with that i wanted to make it like i
said before again we've got to make it
short though
let's make it short and also very very
clear yeah the fact is very simple yeah
what do you think be consistent that's
what we need to say it's very important
they need to be consistent yeah we're
not here very we know
me my team a lot of brothers that i know
yeah yeah we're very vocal
our original prophets has told us about
the warning against isis yeah yeah it's
very clear if anyone if anyone i'm going
to
do
i don't care anyone they can think
whatever they like i'm not going to
please anyone you get it
it's very clear brother our prophet we
follow our religion we don't care about
anyone
our prophet has told us the signs of
this isis
these are these guys yeah okay and
they've killed more muslims
like at the time of the prophet he would
do the kill
us they tried to assassinate
yeah so they have been killing muslims
from day one time they're doing
exactly what they do don't mention all
that the video is going to be too long
bro no we need to because
then they're going to think you know
we're trying to defend it we're not
we're just trying to say it's standard
we've been crossing isis since flipping
day one bro
yeah yeah i've got four right there this
time slightly okay
assalamu alaikum where happens to
brother sisters